Uber could finally hit the brakes on its many dramas...
...now that the ride-sharing app company...
...has offered its top job to a dark horse candidate.
Expedia CEO Dara Khosrowshahi was offered Uber's CEO slot late Sunday...
...after word of Uber's board pick leaked.
As of this taping,...
...we're still waiting for confirmation that Khosrowshahi has actually taken the job.
He's had an interesting life having immigrated from Iran as a child...
...then growing up partially without a father....
...as his dad was not allowed to leave Iran for six years...
...because he'd gone home to care for a sick relative.
Understandably then, Khosrowshahi has been outspoken on Twitter...
...about President Trump's immigration policies.